tell me about who loses in this who's
the loser in all of this because clearly
the companies benefit the employees of
the companies benefit because
they don't suffer dilution they build a
war chest obviously
as an angel investor and a person who
owns an accelerator and
does series a and maybe sometimes keep
your corrada and series b
this is like mark it up let's go yeah
let it ride
let it ride sure you want to take like
you know
my little my little plot of land here
and you want to build a skyscraper on it
build away
yes let's do it break round so who loses
yeah the
the the who loses so so the the the
reason why i really wrote this piece
um was every single week for probably
the last six to nine months i would talk
to an investor friend
at some fund and we would have the tiger
conversation and it was like oh my god
we lost a tiger
i can't believe this founder is taking
the term sheet um
you know oh my god they're over bidding
they you know we couldn't get through
our diligence pro
just all these excuses and you know
eventually i kind of stopped like you
know nodding along
um and i respond and i'm like well one
do you really think that
these people that have been very very
successful for two decades in the public
markets just come into the private
markets and lose 50
iq points probably not and then two like
what are you really offering
founders that they can't offer founders
um if you don't have the brand if you
don't have the signaling if you don't
have a lot of these like really special
things
that really only like five to ten firms
have uh in in
uh in the us at least i don't know about
europe or other
other places like if you don't have
those things like what are you really
giving them
that is better than what tiger can give
them and if when when you dig
even just on those things a tiny bit it
was very clear
that many folks in the industry just
hadn't thought critically at
all about the state of this uh the state
of this asset class
so for me it was kind of like wow like a
lot of people
are are kind of riding blind um and are
asleep at the wheel
um and so i you know i'm not gonna like
name names i don't
at founders fun we try just to care
about our lps our founders and
ourselves and we don't really care what
what other folks are are doing in the
industry but
um there's kind of these like common
attributes and so um
you can kind of tell a firm if they are
really really pitching a lot of
value-added services
um if they don't have the brand of like
a top five or top ten brand where you're
really signaling to the market wow
um you know founders fund is investing
in this company there's probably 10x
upside left after this
there's probably something very special
about the business and if you haven't if
you're not nimble if your organization
structure isn't
um set up such that you can adapt to
these new competitive realities
that is what like that that is what
happened to jcpenney like jcpenney
wanted you know they went through
bankruptcy they tried to come back
but they couldn't they they didn't have
the management they didn't have the
employees that were ready to be nimble
and really shed a lot of that weight
when i saw your piece that immediately
was cathartic for me
because when i came into the industry 11
years ago as an
angel investor scout and i started
placing bets
i was amazed that the vcs over the last
10 years
just decided to go downstream and they
were like you know what we're not going
to demo days anymore
we don't care about you know why
combinator demodado stuff
just literally had somebody at a very
high profile firm
who you know but i won't say who uh say
to me
that's an awesome company i totally want
to be on the cap table
um get to product market fit and i will
overpay
for the series a or series b um but i i
don't want to do all the work for these
first two or three years of that product
market fit journey and i said you know
i happen to like that and i was offered
to go to one of the firms that had like
more of a growth thing and they were
like
you know you could instead of you know
trying to put 25 or 50 million to work a
year in
50 companies j cal you could make one
bet or two a year
and then just hang out the rest of the
year and it's the same amount of money
being deployed and i was like yeah i
just i
kind of like the earlier stage better so
basically now there's
just going to be this demarcation if you
have product market fit
if you've got tens of millions of
revenue
you're basically going to like a bank
and getting financing
as opposed to in the early stage when
you really do need to have some help in
terms of hey what's the business model
here or
what you know why is our design suck or
what how do we grow this thing or do you
know anybody who could be a
a cfo or at least or at least it's an
option right like you know maybe you
know every time you want money maybe you
don't go to
the the bank of cheap capital because
maybe there is somebody that can really
move the needle with your business or
really you know you really get along
with an investor and you're like you
know what we're going to be 100 billion
dollar company
you know two extra points of dilution
doesn't matter um but i think it's i
think it's a healthy thing
for founders uh and that's all we really
care about at least is like
it's a healthy thing for founders that
this is available and if they want to
take it
they can because it's a better product
than what a lot of folks are putting out
there
uh in the early stage people were
lamenting oh my god angel lists and
syndicates nobody no
founders will ever do those that's going
to be a negative signal and now of
course
syndicates are a vibrant part of the
ecosystem
and then equity crowdfunding people are
looking at that going oh that's just
silly and then we saw sahil raise five
million in a day
with no there's no venture partner in
that model when you do a republic
or a seed invest there's no investor
that's just the founder
selling directly to the public so do you
think there's something
similar or analogous here that could
happen a little bit earlier
or is the earlier stage just so much
work that it's
it's it's not as easy as a you know
uh you know how much what's your revenue
you know send me your p
l here's your here send me your cac
here's your here's your check
i i think it'll be a mix and i think i
think that because
the the every round size is getting
better bigger you know like seeds as you
mentioned
there's kind of this like you know what
a seed is today used to be an a
what an a is today used to be a b so you
just have a lot more room to work with
um but i do think that there might be
this kind of like mix of where you get
the institution that you want you get
the
signaling of the institution you get the
board member that you want you get
um the brand you get all that stuff but
you still have room to involve
either if it's individuals or people
with rolling funds uh angellist
et cetera um also in the round and so
maybe now instead of
uh you know a seed fund or c day fund
doing
all of a round you have them be the lead
and then you have 30 to 40 percent
um of the round also allocated to all
the other things that are popping up
because i think there's
a lot of individual value add that some
of these folks especially it's like yeah
it's like you have
some people that are just absolute
experts uh whether it's in a sector or
at a function
and you're like wow like i just want to
know their you know marketing network
uh because you don't know any marketers
and and that's what you're gonna be
focused on for the next 12 months why
not give them a little bit of allocation
like that i think that makes
a lot of sense and there's just a lot
more room to work with these days than
there was previously
it does feel to me like um
the middle layer of this capital stack
is just been absolutely squashed you
know it's just
there's really if you don't get into
those early rounds
you're not getting into the startup end
of the day like if you look at something
like
i don't know clubhouse the hottest deal
of the last year um
i mean kind of weird um
to have injuries and do three rounds in
14 months from 100 million to 4 billion
with no revenue and collapsing downloads
putting that putting that aside i'm
you're not in that deal i take it
we are not we are not um if you didn't
get in in that 100 million
or seed round or whatever it was like
you're not getting in now right it's
like the ships
unless the founder just absolutely loves
you and wants to carve out
a little 25k or 50k check for you either
you get in early or you don't which in a
way
i kind of like because it makes
investors take risk
which i took huge risk in my bets
you know i invested in com and uber and
robinhood and these things before they
had product market fit
and then everybody wants to be a hero
and invest in them when they're at a
billion and then put them on their
in their bios and i'm like i kind of
know that you bought secondary shares
on like some websites yeah you don't get
to call yourself an angel
you know an airbnb because you bought it
three months before the ipo
well i think it brings up um another
good topic which is the the third avenue
which is they can come in
and come in over the top and really
overpay just like tiger and i think
what some of these jc fun penny funds
are already doing and we'll see a lot of
them do
which i think is a bad response to kind
of the tiger phenomenon
or the crossover phenomenon is they will
try to emulate it they're going to say
you know what we need to get these hot
deals
let's overpay let's quicken our
diligence process
let's keep getting into these deals and
when you don't have the scale of
tiger and you don't have the index fund
where you're
you know invested in a hundred of these
things instead of six
um you can get wiped out if you if you
miss the uh if you miss a swing or two
uh
this is gonna be the risk build for it
yeah yeah it's gonna be the risk of ruin
right
like you're going to overpay an entry
price does matter
in a smaller fund whereas a big fund
they can withstand it you know they they
hit one zoom
or one airbnb or one coinbase like they
could they can withstand this and
they're also
playing with you know tens of billions
of dollars in capital
of which this is you know going to be
five billion right
and it's just not going to
be as much of an impact on it